hey nina what's up hey tom i'm working
on a piece about all the spider-man
movies before no way home and i could
use a little recap well that might be
hard we're on our eighth movie and third
reboot in two decades there's a lot of
ground to cover that's all right just
start from the beginning pretend you're
explaining spider-man to a woman who
couldn't care less wow it's like this is
what i've been training for my entire
life all right so depending on which
franchise you're watching peter parker
is a nerdy high school student who's
either 19 28 or two weeks from
retirement
uh-huh and he either gets bitten by a
genetically engineered spider covered in
a bunch of genetically engineered
spiders or the movie assumes that you
saw the first five origin stories and
skips all that crap in any case he finds
himself quite suddenly able to do all
the things that a spider do can i get a
few examples well he can stick to things
he can shoot things that stick to things
and of course you can use the sticky
things that he shoots to stick things to
other things so marvel's most popular
superhero is a teenage boy whose hands
are just always sticky yeah you get it
cool okay just making sure that i'm
keeping up
so
this spider-man yes spider-man does
whatever a spider can that's correct is
he strong hey listen bud he's got
radioactive blood
so no no he's very sick got it go on
thanks to his newfound stickiness peter
parker is instilled with a new sense of
self-confidence and starts to go down
the wrong path either with tobey maguire
participating in blood sport and
homophobia or andrew garfield playing
basketball too mean
luckily he has his uncle ben there to
guide his way toby maguire's uncle ben
teaches him that with great power there
must also come great responsibility well
that's succinct and easy to remember you
think that's great just wait because
andrew garfield's uncle ben says
something equally iconic hold on a
second let me look it up
right according to this andrew
garfield's uncle ben says that if you
spider can do good things for other
people you have a moral obligation to do
those things and tom holland peter
parker drops another zippy morality
banger when he tells tony stark that
when you can do the things that he
spider can but you don't and the bad
things happen they happen because of
spider you
wow the t-shirts just write themselves
toby mcguire spider-man fights a guy
who's mad about work and then a guy
who's mad about science andrew garfield
spider-man fights a guy who's mad about
science and then a guy who's mad about
work both spider-man wait until the last
movie in their franchise to drastically
overcrowd things to the point where
their story is practically unbearable
it's great so what about tom holland
spider-man totally different so when
they brought him into the mcu it was
kind of a fresh start for the characters
so they decided to try something new so
he fights a guy who's mad about work and
then a guy who's mad about science so
does he wait until his very last movie
to overcrowd everything until the story
is totally unbearable
no
no no
no
no
no
probably not terrific let's talk romance
is there a mrs spider-man on the scene
you'd better believe it sister tobey
maguire spider-man is in love with
kirsten dunst mary jane okay great what
happens with them peter breaks up her
marriage and then goes to her work and
punches her neat andrew garfield well he
was gonna have a mary jane but they cut
her out of the movie to make room for
stuff like subway token mysteries and
paul giamatti so instead he dates gwen
stacy up until he you know breaks her
neck and kills her
tom holland he beats up his first
girlfriend's dad so bad that she has to
move and then in the next movie he hooks
up with zendaya but like
she's probably gonna be fine right
she'll probably be fine we should in no
way read too much into the fact that by
this point in their respective
franchises both of the other spider-man
had been to like four funerals and tom
holland's only been to one
[Music]
she is probably gonna be fine and no way
home is not going to be another in a
series of overstuffed final entries in
the spider-man saga right
[Music]
no
nina
nina are you still there
nina i didn't even get to tell you about
peter's aunt may
she keeps benjamin buttoning between
movies
to get millie bobby brown to play her in
the next one
nina